AT COLUMBIA RECORDS,
AND THEN HIS MOTHER WRITES HIM
A LETTER--
YOUR HERO, JOHNNY CASH,
IS A DRUG ADDICT,
AND OF COURSE HE SINGS
AT SAN QUENTIN
AND FOLSOM RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE A JAILBIRD
SINGS WITH JAILBIRDS,
SO WE HAVE NOW OFFICIALLY
DISOWNED YOU.
I HOPE SOMEHOW YOU COME
TO YOUR SENSES,
'CAUSE YOU'RE NOT
A SONGWRITER.
SORRY, KRIS.
YOU'RE DONE.
AND HE FELT LIKE
A GIANT FAILURE.
HE'S A [bleep] JANITOR.
AND THEN ONE DAY
JOHNNY CASH COMES IN.
HE'S LIKE, WHO IN THE WORLD
IS IN THERE RIGHT NOW
CHANGING THE ASHTRAYS
WITH THOSE BROWN--
WITH THE INCREDIBLE
BLUE EYES?
WELL, IT'S KRIS.
WHO IS HE?
HIS MOM JUST DISOWNED HIM
BECAUSE YOU'RE HIS HERO.
AND KRIS WAS IN THERE
CHANGING THE ASHTRAYS,
AND JOHNNY CASH COMES IN
AND SAYS,
WELL, IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO GET
A LETTER FROM HOME, AIN'T IT?
AND KRIS CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
HE'S LIKE, YEAH.
BUT THEY BONDED OVER IT,
BECAUSE HE WAS PASSIONATE
AND HE HAD HIS DREAM.
I'M GONNA QUIT ALL THIS,
AND I WANT TO PURSUE
AN ARTIST'S LIFE.
SO HE QUIT.
KRIS IS STARVING.
HE HAS NO MONEY.
HE'S NOW WRITING
THESE SONGS.
AND THEN KRIS, SO FRUSTRATED,
AND HE HAS ONE SONG.
IT'S ABOUT THAT FEELING
TO BE ON A SUNDAY
WHEN THE BARS DON'T OPEN,
AND IT'S CALLED
SUNDAY MORNING COMING DOWN.
IT'S A THAT FEELING,
LONELINESS
AND NOBODY BELIEVING IN YOU
BUT YOU
AND WISHING,
LORD, THAT I WAS STONED,
'CAUSE THERE AIN'T NOTHING
IN A SUNDAY
THAT MAKES A BODY
FEEL ALONE.
SUNDAY MORNING COMING DOWN
WAS THE SONG KRIS KNEW
WAS SOMETHING SPECIAL.
HOW CAN I GET MY SONG
TO JOHNNY CASH
AND MAKE AN IMPACT?
SO, FOR JOHNNY,
KRIS LANDED A HELICOPTER
IN HIS LAWN
TO GIVE HIM THIS SONG.
SOME FOOL'S LANDING
IN OUR YARD WITH A HELICOPTER
RIGHT OUT OF THE SKY.
HE REALLY LISTENED TO THE SONG,
AND THE SONG WENT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL FOR JOHNNY,
BECAUSE HE UNDERSTOOD IT.
HE UNDERSTOOD THE ISOLATION
AND THE LONELINESS
AND WISHING,
LORD, THAT HE WAS STONED.
EXCUSE ME.
- YOU'RE FINE.
- [burps]